oh that really hurts it is really loud
how did anyone survive this is the worst
you can't see [ __ ] in this thing you
don't up saying hey what's up not MVP
hey everybody
wow that chats going real fast I can't
read anyone's comments especially cuz I
can't see in this thing
alright I went through the whole process
of getting this helmet and we can't even
play forever but it's dead yeah we're
gonna play next week or the week after
instead we're gonna play a little game
called Resident Evil 7 maybe you've
heard of it and if you haven't well put
your big-boy pants on and pull them up
cuz we about to get crazy up in here
hello everyone good to see you lost in
twitch verse what's up my visor looks
like a cheese grater how do you see some
you know maybe maybe we should just play
Resident Evil in a helmet let's do it
that's gonna be fun and look at this
look and you know what I got a special
helmet over here check this [ __ ] out
oh yeah this one it's heavier
it's Kyle gilded it's a real gold by the
way alright so let's do it we're gonna
start the game I'm in normal of course
something I'm not obviously here we go
Matthew what you want one of these
helmets this is gonna get pretty scary
it smells awful by the way it smells
[Music]
it's our girlfriend thank you no put me
in the lower-left it's beautiful this is
a beautiful yes I won the lottery and I
spent all my money on these helmets very
cool no VR sorry guys it's we are be
boring to watch for you
it doesn't smell terrible you know what
this is that's a bad idea you got longer
that's right
hey what's up Pisces aam be good to see
you guys is this a good look for me
yes no in the chat
this is this arm this mirrors the
emotional armor I have on me at all
times
she was flossing those gasps between the
teeth you were right
I don't know how anybody survived back
in the day oh if you get a lower left
O'Malley is that okay sorry this is the
gun it's definitely I really have lost
weight what's the secret I don't eat any
beep don't drink beer don't eat any
bread or pasta that's what it is live a
life of sadness nice treat on your day
off
well there we go mark good to see you ah
here we go
look at those drives awesome it's easy
this helmet your is a knight's helmet
thank you very much yeah let's see
you're trying to stab all bleh not gonna
work you can't get in what about this
side no she's what about the back no
don't think so I don't know and also it
opens like this I don't know I didn't
know that yeah let's check that out
it's like wants me to come together okay
the pieces fall off
Vince thank you this thing my head is
gonna smell like metal I know I know
what if it is I have to find how happen
happen yeah everyone spam where's Conan
cuz that'll make him show up good idea
guys
yeah cone is probably in the chat as
cone bones 69 can you have a job working
for us yes yes max the rat you take my
job you can make our Internet butter I'm
drinking diet coke because life has no
meaning you know what I don't know how
well I don't know how well that would
protect against pepper spray I'm gonna
be honest probably not very well because
I feel like like look at these well
there's big holes in there you know
should I actually try to play this with
the hell man I mean it would hey what up
homie what up yourself chap my objective
boom find Mia so we're looking for our
wife she's been missing for three years
her name's Mia she just made that cool
YouTube video we just saw where she was
horrified and this is the house we're
gonna try to go in locked of course it's
4 a.m. now in Indonesia what a nice time
to play Resident Evil Oh baby you're
gonna be scared it gets scary
I'm gonna say in about 30 to 45 seconds
oh by the way Beth loves fire watch you
guys don't you like this game is awesome
so good I sue the sewer Gators I really
like reading materials why don't you
check out the back of this joy could be
ketchup dude someone's recommending
accept her gift changing the gamma
changing the gamma that's not even
oh you want to make it darker is that
your thing contract you dicks
alright fine blood on screen less I say
normal camera wobble on tutorial phone
icon yes yes hood on all right fine I
hope you all are happy I got bad eyes
I'm old did somebody say something about
my old man spectacles there you guys
happy now it's suitably creepy here we
go
Oh Beth prepare yourself yourself
prepares a dude walking I love it ooh
darker yes one of my favorite things
this is a weird moment but I love
Louisiana is a great setting for a
horror just birds relax what's this it's
just a couple buzz saws and a bunch of
limbs put together do a giant spider
thing oh yeah
that's reaction cam I wish we had a
separate reaction cam for Beth can't
wait it was just it was her birthday
yesterday everyone now I didn't make it
to Beth's birthday no party I was
invited I really wanted to go I had
stuck
I was started drinking out at my house
it's a pre game and I ended up getting
too drunk to leave the house and I'm a
sad pathetic loser it wasn't fun
hey look it's Mia's bag what and there's
her driver's license Texas got goo on it
let's check our let's check our thing
how convenient we can't tell how old she
is if I was a bouncer I would not let
her into a bar you know say you know
this seems like a cool non completely
[ __ ] scary house to go into pregame
drinking and missed the game yeah
exactly
that is like my mo I'm the worst person
ever okay Beth ready for this ready for
this oh it gets way worse luckily we
have a flashlight and so it begins
and so it begins
scary scary wasn't it
I can't open nothing ooh yeah hey who's
hungry
who's hungry it's lunch time who's
hungry YUM wearing you know what I'm
gonna put on ye olde subtitles we love
them we know them well why is it not
there subtitles should be in your boy
needs a subtitles yo I'll give you
language roaches no vr sorry Cody we're
not doing this in VR at least not today
you're looking here there's a creepy
photo of someone doing something
let's look in here it's locked
eat a dick what's that Beth do you want
to open the microwave sure oh what's
that
leftovers they keep their garbage in
there through this home is this I think
Mick Cena's 60fps but stream is 30 we're
streaming 60 baby how dare you where do
we go back up or down like this I'm
gonna fuse it looks like to me let's
play a little tune shall we big so Beth
hates the street we don't have a tape
yet I do love the decor look at these
folks
looks like the owners
ooh a prison cell
no chopsticks for you love resin I
definitely I'm definitely gonna play
this game in VR for sure but not today
oh it's a guy staring creepily at a girl
that's my tinder profile pic you guys
alright
looks like pictures of my wife let's go
over here what's in here
this must be Conan's office yes we're
playing in Conan's office how astute of
you how did you guys know ooh there's
some gross goo gross cue anyone let's go
up here a flashing button let's hit it
in no worky boo a videotape derelict
house footage don't mind if I do
let's save our game yes please
Tony's gonna smack me that's true he's
already smacking much today I had some
great pancakes this weekend you tell her
it was my birthday you tella
strawberries whoo creme fraiche heard of
it Oh Mike yeah where did you go house
of pies no it was place called baby's
Burbank minute wait usually good
pancakes go to baby's house of pies also
great pancakes all right we gonna watch
some footage you ready to watch the
derelict house footage
oh my god let's do it color bars
derelict house Clancy Jameis javis del V
haunted house rehearsal oh this game is
about Conan trying to find his tinder
date by the way I love this like we're
in the footage like see we're actually
moving around in the footage isn't it
cool hey this is Conan's office during
his first few years at NBC no it's not
that's right actually we should be still
so Mike yeah we have actually coming up
with a little bit guys we're gonna show
an outtake from our awesome Superbowl
clueless gamer it should be very fun but
Tom Brady quite free that's right so
post the link anyway I'm happy to take
questions about it which was it was very
fun unless you guys want to keep writing
I need to poop really badly
well the vhj VHS tape was very wild
that's consider at least be kind rewind
I hate this guy by the way
that's stupid [ __ ] in the jacket I
want that guy to die
say hi to Fred somebody's asking Beth
can you say hi to Fred there you go now
you have to wish Beth a happy birthday
yeah yeah yeah language bro
I do like look how they kind of made it
wavy like a VHS tape it's very cool so
basically I've been playing this game a
little bit basically the idea is and
these VHS tapes which are basically
flashbacks you learn stuff about where
you can you look it's like clues you're
supposed to pay attention and look look
around for stuff because things are
different than they are when you go
through see there's no picture in there
that's still locked
see like there's nothing in here Lucas
their son is Pan
where's Andre
keep the camera in Andre we lost Andre
the bad seed get him that's ego I have
to say this Beth right now if you and me
are in a haunted house you disappear I'm
just leaving is that okay what also by
the way leave me if I am somewhere just
leave me to die I wouldn't leave yeah I
know absolutely I'm giving I'm telling
you right now leave me to die Oh leave
me to die it's not worth it Beth Oh
Andre no I loved you the guy complained
about his shoes is basically tarnish
Lansky yeah that's true well Pete gets
killed
yeah that's the rule don't go after
anybody just save yourself man
save yourself where's Andre Conan would
leave both of us in a heartbeat
uh-oh secret passageway no we just leave
see [ __ ] Andre let's just leave him who
cares about Andre sorry Andre we don't
care about you just be quite I think you
meant quiet Carolina or maybe you meant
quite sexy
here's where they keep their newspapers
you know it makes good kindling this is
a great idea let's go down a ladder in a
rotted floorboard
oh this is great why would I even go in
I don't know what would I hate touch of
red what's up love frustrate a squid a
file yeah this is the people under the
stairs chainsaw guys by the way since I
got a great movie such a foul language
you know you know what I I hope this
game has Purell in it cuz this is gross
like that look at this this is filthy
look at this ladder it's disgusting I
think it's Andre what I think it's Andre
Andre Andre Andre
[Music]
PAHs man you know she's a bad format
maybe think I had a bunch of magnets on
him or something but now we know yeah
now we know to open this time to go time
cuz you know we should do
retrace their steps going down there
something different will happen
oh there seems to be by the way more
garbage over here than there was but
Andre was down here a hundred what have
I told you about drinking bleach
cleaners OMG it is horror game this game
reminds me of a tuning in from Sweden
this game reminds me of a family reunion
you had I mean ever to come to your face
I'm drinking a diet cherry coke Zero
yeah it's good it's delicious it's bad
for you but I'm doing it
Portugal there we go jigsaw well this is
awful
oh man now we got to get the water now
we got to get in the water now we got to
get in the water now we're in the water
this is terrible this is terrible
by the way look at the skim on the
surface that water that's so gross now
we're in the water
enjoy bone cancer and no kidding I'm
gonna sue the ladder the microwave the
camera robber avenges soon everybody by
the way I would too this is terrible
oh there's bubbling there's bubbling
there's bubbling
maybe I'm just farting a lot you're
nervous I'm free yeah I'm a nervous I'm
nervous for tea person yep this is no
way this is good no way this is good no
way this is good yeah Jesus Christ is
that uh can I get past this dude is that
Andre first of all we couldn't find him
now we can't get rid of them am i right
I'm putting the helmet on I don't need
this I need the helmet I need to feel
safe all right this is the opposite of
VR by the way I'm actually yeah I can't
really see in this thing but then it got
I can't really oh look at this can't
really see anyway
that is that noise by the way everything
is echoing here does this sound like I'm
yelling it feels like I'm yelling I
really take it down
Hey look ah here's my wife bolt cutters
time to cut some bolts snip it off baby
you know what everyone in the Middle
Ages probably smelled awful my head is
already heating up can this like go
there's no way for this change you know
this needs like a little kickstand yeah
he needs like a little it's like a piece
of wood or something I could shove in
here
well it doesn't smell like vomit and
armpits so it's better than the
masturbating America but now I'm
masturbating bear Kozma smells like me
so there you go oh don't turn her over
dude don't turn her over doe to him oh
she's hot
yeah here give me that thing I know they
didn't have tape and Middle Ages who are
you talking about I'm just gonna like
tape this it's gonna work I just tape
this open boom the other me be wearing
guillotine on my face you know whoa all
right ah my whole face smells like metal
so to a regular Monday what did she say
I wasn't paying attention daddy
it was creepy hey daddy's here baby
yeah you know what let's go back the
other way out the way we came
yeah she's definitely just like Pantene
pro-v or something oh my god more tape
you think you think more tape would do
it maybe one on each side you know what
if something scary happens again I'm
gonna go back in the thing oh that's a
noise what are we doing oh look at this
sorry sorry baby why are you looking I'm
down here oh this is gross this is gross
this is gross there's gross things over
here what the [ __ ] are those things so
many in this room I believe or said
they're Honey Baked hams
they've just been this is where they
store all their ham this is ham storage
creeper yeah not MVP hello my eyes are
down here I don't actually think you're
telling me everything you know
cuz you call them daddy it's here daddy
this is a dead end
I really want some ham most youtubers do
the same thing when streaming the game
what they put on a helmet of course
that's like if you have few a hospital
room we're bound to get help here it's
really wet down here there's probably
mold do you think we're breathing in
mold spores yeah great you know what I'm
sure this is a way out of the house
great this is probably where the game
ends I am gonna try I am Robo back I'm
in trouble in this indie are all right
chill out dude
he 0:01 it says
we're just going to sleep yeah I know
dude
more booty shots mold spores that people
turn to the last ones you're right
cordyceps oh i can't wait for the last
of us to I'm very excited all right I'm
gonna find us something creepy dolls ah
yeah let's go running after her terrible
idea a terrible idea a terrible idea
terrible idea why am i doing this why am
I doing this
wow great call for help okay that's my
nan scary grandma Jordan is the boss
villain in this game hi Deshawn wills
first aid gonna need that gonna need
that boy I don't like it this is
basically my apartment hello melis
laughing yes it's true I the way I live
in filth guys it's not a question Taco
boys alright here we go
you know what I don't like pounding
alright I feel like something really
Bad's gonna happen
[Music]
okay I'll take that Matt are you ready
bet I'm nervous I'm nervous all right
let's go
hello hello dear
do you hear something do you hear
something
Oh Beth Beth Beth Beth Beth oh yeah gosh
[ __ ] ah god this is why you don't go
back from people this is why you don't
go back for people Jesus Christ this is
why don't go back for people leave me
alone I'm resisting resist Trump resist
true them get the knife get the night
dude hey chill out show up you chill
chill Jesus kick her in the uterus
wherever you kick girls oh that knife is
bad she's out oh my god leave Britney
Alone yeah do that more do that more yep
do it harder hit your head harder yeah
you're right you're right you do oh
thank god
whew
yeah hashtag issues dude yeah that'll I
got stabbed through the hand that'll
help
good God all right well you know what a
bad idea in a horror movie is stepping
over a dead body
maybe we just run past oh yeah now it's
locked
oh dude come on man don't make me keep
stepping over oh [ __ ] she's gonna be
right behind me isn't she well this is
awkward that moment when your wife who's
been missing for three years turns into
a zombie and stabs you through the hand
and the knocks herself out and lays in
the hallway hashtag relatable do I have
to like yup yup I knew it I knew she was
coming back come on I would love to
leave you by the way I would love that
Jesus get backs get the axe
what now were you mad yeah well I got an
axe huh
can I please just do some stabbing there
we go finally get her in the face
this is how first date normally goes for
me all the way this is why you can't get
back with your exes yep right in the
face right in the face
get her it oh yes oh my god oh now she's
okay can I like get that axe back or
something dude
so just go I would definitely take that
axe back Jesus Christ
completed in VRS is read by nature this
sums up all my relationships that's even
yeah well mine too
oh wait your phone could you keep it
down
no he's complaint no she's dead I'm sure
that's the last time you've seen her
language you can't have the axe back man
my girl attacked me she took my favorite
axe with what is that
I just waste that medicine oh great
she's gone cool
well at least I got my axe back that's
what you're saying I stabbed her in the
neck and that's what you're upset about
the blood puddle I got everything I just
I like that why does the phone look old
why does everything in here look old
it's the better question
there's my blood okay great this is open
carnival of Horrors
oh now we're back to this room I wasn't
there something like a sir something I
couldn't open with the bolt cutters back
through here I think right I hate all
this I hate this kitchen I hate this
house I hate my wife I hate snip it up
the boo-boo she calls her the stairs
like the garage but she looks like a
Deadite another handy evil dead
reference will be along shortly
perfect yeah man this game is dope aah
aah
did you see that she just walked by the
doorway I got my ax come on bring it
where's the fuse box set oh that shadows
scared me dude I don't need this game
she's gonna be right in here I don't
need it I don't need it this stairs on
the thing
oh let's you know what I bet this uh
let's go upstairs
ah [ __ ] Jesus Christ it's me you've got
a giant axe wound in your yep get her in
the head with the urks get her in okay
oh oh that seems unnecessary pull that
out dude pull out the screwdriver pull
out the screwdriver
I'm putting the helmet back on
I'm putting the helmet back on I don't
need this Oh God oh my god get her with
the axe bro Jesus
hey it's my hands bleeding
[Applause]
dude my stump is just straight-up like
bleeding what are you seeing this my
stuff is just straight-up bleeding hot
what do I do
I don't have any more medicine uh am I
gonna like die here it's definitely
gonna get infected in this house
yeah this is good let's go further into
the house no thanks
I'm gonna save right now there's so much
that's out for the stump not if not a
stump fan a bandage to the work says Rep
Donna regenerate Deadpool style I wish I
could do
how do I where do I go with my stump
I need sauce I need first aid sauce
going up maybe there's some upstairs
Jesus Christ Oh God by the way I would
be dead by now easily I've got thrown
through two walls
I need the first-aid [ __ ] man
Oh gun finally oh here we go yeah can't
reload it I only have one frickin hand
there we go medicine this will
definitely help me I don't need to use
that right now are you serious haha I've
got one hand
you don't need the hands I don't need to
worry about it right now I've only got
one freaking hand whatever gotta be
kidding me
oh Jesus Christ all right Mike hey I've
got a bloody stump are you serious with
this right now all right all right I got
some bullets pain don't hurt what's the
sound of one hand clapping me go get my
hand oh you know what wait did I bleep
is my hand downstairs did Mia like eat
it or something
Wow I don't know how I ever married this
girl by the way she seems like a real
real moody you know real moody where
does she cut off my hand I can't even
remember now
I was down here oh my now just blacked
out
once you cut off like over here or
something right I'd be so dead right now
damn it where did my hand go don't you
hate it when you lose your hand all the
time there's blood everywhere
[ __ ] hey oh here we go can I pick up my
hand oh I got it hey look I got my hand
happy birthday happy birthday bad the
three year anniversary is the hand
anniversary yeah exactly yeah it's flesh
it's paper wood than flesh I think it's
Santa bite all right well I'm sure
things can't get any worse
hey let's go up this ladder what do you
say I don't know we're about to see oh
[ __ ] yep here we go
there she is I knew she - it
I'm mr. I don't think it has to come
down
my god I keep missing her [ __ ] yeah
oh my god she's real this oh she got me
oh boy - Kurt - Kurt - Kurt yeah she's
got me she's oh oh oh oh oh oh oh no oh
that was that was horrific dude he just
wrote dude mmm drench that stump alright
well that sucked I think we should run
out into the hallway yeah I feel like
staying in the same room
yeah she's dangerous with no [ __ ] you
should try to shoot her with your gun
yeah thanks dick okay
take a gun okay okay fine all right
let's go get all the mad Elda [ __ ] we
had before well I'm not doing half bad
for reloading with a guy with one hand I
just want that out there all right
well it's here somebody's been sleeping
here this looks disgusting
by the way ladies that is my bed so when
you you ever make it to my bedroom
that's what it looks like which is why
no ladies make it to my bedroom okay
here we go
all right we got the bullets we're
feeling good we got the first aid kit
she's not gonna take us by surprise now
we know what to do all right so here's
here I think here's the move we try to
pop her when she's coming down the
ladder all right and then I think maybe
we just run out to the hallway I'm not
gonna go up the ladder by the way
I can get her up here oh she comes right
at me Jesus
run away run away
do you think we round on the hallway now
I can just keep got oh haha [ __ ] run out
to the hallway round alway open the door
open the door open the door open the
door back up back up back up
oh [ __ ] oh I got her quick one in the
head come on no I get hurt shoot her in
the face
[ __ ] god damn it get her in the helmets
going I've had it I got my armor on
we're tuning again we're gonna beat this
level before the stream ends that's my
promise no tape necessary let's tuck the
moderate alright I'm ready
nothing can hurt me or scare me when I'm
in my thing I also can't see the chat
very well okay here we go let's go
ah this is it Beth we're gonna do it
this is this game is taking years off of
our lives we have to do this we have to
beat it okay we're gonna beat this we're
gonna beat this girl I'm gonna shoot her
a bunch of times in the face then we're
gonna watch a cut scene from the
clueless gamer it's all gonna make us
feel good alright guys don't worry I got
this I got it everybody don't worry I'm
really glad we got these things we're
honored here because this is really
helping me out alright where's the
goddamn bullets over here okay we're
ready let's go let's do it I'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
I'd like to go back home
ah [ __ ]
soon as you can't open doors
I
yes yes we did it
[Music]
wait a second though wait a second yeah
I got a shooter in the head just to make
sure she's definitely gonna come back to
life
right right she's gonna grab me or
something oh I knew it I knew it oh no
oh come on wait a different dude coming
in hot
hahaha he's not finished installing
looks like we beat the game that's right
all right well guys before we go we have
a suite we played for honor with Tom
Brady Dwight Freeney LeGarrette Blount
Rob Gronkowski Marshawn Lynch and Conan
O'Brien last weekend in Houston and we
put as a close gamer it's super funny
we had Erin Andrews do a sideline report
she was amazing but we had so much great
stuff that Tom Brady
we couldn't shove it all in to the
clueless gamer so over the next kind of
a week or two we're gonna be putting out
some extra stuff from the gamer and we
have a special cutscene of Tom Brady
we're gonna show you guys right now and
this is actually where Conan and Tom
before they started playing Conan kind
of asked Tom about being competitive and
this is what happened so enjoy this very
short cut I would take a clueless gamer
on tape coming your way this could get
really intense maybe let's say are you
in competitive about anything let's say
you and I were each netting a scarf and
I was a little ahead of you would you
notice that and start to knit faster no
I just take yours away and then
would be violent it wouldn't be by light
now you just take it away and I would
just wilt just get a chance to do
anything and there it is the goat
greatest of all time Tom Brady now you
know what happened if you tried to go up
against him in scarf knitting yeah so uh
don't you do it
he's the greatest at football and a
scarf and he might actually be better
knitting than playing football well we
actually have never seen it yeah that's
right competitive knitting guys thank
you so much for joining us for this
stream cocoa and for dealing with
artists sanity during playing Resident
Evil 7 what a nightmare a literal
nightmare we'll be playing much more of
this and if we're honor and the weeks to
come and we'll see you guys next week on
monday at noon pacific right back here
for some cocoa watch the show tonight
watch the show I will see you guys next
week
see you later bye
you